me acordem
pensei o que vou fazer não posso me
esconder
tenho muito aprenda
seguindo na paz sem olhar para trás
conferência jamais caiu na área agora
que a trata não vou me machucar só que
temperatura faz com que eu lembro que
eu posso
conhecer e poder tiver cada segundo o
meu bem querer
ser livre na
[Música]
praia
não perco
[Música]
meu tempo é precioso e eu preciso
sempre que
posso tocar e para
mais
para saber como
[Música]
melhorar tem que fazer menor tenho
vivência
o nosso futuro tá na nossa mão na
consciência é
mais no que pensar só ela tá ligado tá
ligado é uma pode causar
é
[Música]
preciso de um pra outro obrigado ela
pode causar
é princípio
[Música]
E
ontem o que vou fazer não posso me
esconder
tenho muito
aprender essa saia